item 1 apologies we've got apologies
probably counselor Judy didn't believe
there any more item to substitute agenda
item number 3 no members attending
counselor mrs. coy
and item number 4 minutes of the meeting
held in the city of February 2018 is
being circulated absolutely amazing I
believe there was going to be in a day I
haven't I must be honest rent is that it
was going to be an explanation this
because we were given information at the
last meeting that program
to be inaccurate I understand from
councillor Mason that there was going to
be a no put on something to that effect
because the information obviously
physics in the public domain the
interest rate that was quoted by the
portfolio holder I believe it was for
was it all was it really wasn't by the
officers whatever whoever quoted it the
information that was counted on interest
rates on the meeting was incorrect and
obviously whilst we can talk to the
minute because the minute that except
he's after that we shouldn't allow that
error to be perpetuated believed he had
some communication listened you know
German up I'm happy to contribute and
saying that's correct that my
correspondent was mister Gower's yeah
yes it was correct so you know in on
this it should be in a danger wanna know
till the minute till the fact that the
information was incorrect and to perhaps
put the correct information and what
they don't
we don't you know social subject to that
kind of subject at that conclusion
conclusion
yeah which only be a matter arising from
the minutes Joe yeah yeah we don't have
much of a rising the ejector which we
did say any declarations of interest
number six is the Community Safety
Partnership for this item we welcome use
the most sisters Director of Community
and Housing Services and counselors
community Thank You chief inspector Glen
Wesley was due to business apologies as
the major incident occurred today that
his he and his team are still pending
[Applause]
thank you very much members and thank
Jack I don't like to start with an
apology but as I say Glen Wesley is on a
serious incident I did detailing the
report that he went to give an update on
the local crime statistics so I
apologize if I'm not able to answer some
of your questions but if you do have any
happy to see you afterwards or I can
know them and Glen Wesley said he wasn't
happy to respond to them as soon as he
can so really just quickly to sum up the
paper and just to note the quarter three
update from the Community Safety
Partnership action plan which I gave a
link to in the report and also to
endorse the new partnership priorities
that have been assessed former strategic
assessment which I attached to the
report just to recap the priorities for
next year some of which are the same but
dwelling burglary is being protective
line of all people and violence against
the person the action plan which
underpins those things is still being
talked about by the steering group we've
got a meeting next week to drill those
actions down but you can imagine in live
to believe some of the actions will be
carried forward from this year's those
that have already proven to have quite
good impacts such as crucial crew senior
safe today and also probably to draw out
one of the actions that's occurring at
the moment is the one-to-one support
that we're giving domestic abuse
survivors at the moment which is proving
very successful and all the awareness
that goes with it so that be carrying
forward also just to note really you
know there's still room for food glue we
still need to work as closely as we can
with our police partners and you know
joint patrolmen which we did a couple of
years ago now and we probably haven't
done it is effectively this year's we
could have done so I think there's a bit
more scope of work to do there
and also just quickly to amend item 7
which was resource implications that the
grant for next financial year wasn't
known and at that time it wasn't but
we've just heard it's going to be
exactly the same as it was last year
here which he sent 12,300 counsel mrs.
Mason thank you can I just ask what
you're saying for the domestic abuse
that we are giving one-to-one assistance
presuming that's to the victim yeah are
there any efforts being made to assist
the perpetrator of domestic abuse to
prevent them very offending that I mean
that I'm sure we've all seen there's
been some programs has been articles
written with input into the perpetrator
to make them understand the impact and
that the method of their should we say
behavior has actually reduced
reoffending and of course it's it breaks
the cycle and I wonder if there's been
any consideration to that aspect of
domestic abuse
locally we haven't done any perpetrator
programs County wise there are
perpetrator programs and I know the
police have one as well but so we
haven't done anything locally we just
feed into the county once cap can't that
be considered perhaps going forward
certainly you know we can certainly put
that forward as part of our partnership
discussions next week thank you
Thank You Sharon item item seven there's
also indications you very finally spoke
about the the grant can I ask what the
criteria is Criterion's the criteria
that determine how much grant is
provided to each district
I suppose my concern is I a fair
distribution through to our district to
other districts get more what criteria
are applied and why if we get the
precept for the Police Crime Commission
and be increased why hasn't the budget
missed I can't answer that question
fully I'll be able to follow up
obviously with the obvious of peaceful I
inquire Commissioner it hasn't increased
as you say it's been top slice last year
as well for domestic homicide reviews so
it's got slightly less how it's worked
out I think it's historic it hasn't
changed for a long time about how that's
done the detail I would have liked to
get that China German I'm only
interested that we're getting the fair
crack compared to other other districts
and that some historic situation hasn't
arisen whereby we're aware of the you
know the short end and then in
particular if you do increase the
precept then you expect the same thing
comments or any increase in appropriate
budget so our thought community safety
was an important perspective of
increasing the budget before that I've
got one other question and I don't think
he'll be able to answer this one but
please excuse me for asking it
I was really pleased to see that there's
been a 33 percent decrease in
acquisitive crime in other words
dwelling very very 81 offense in salad
now that could be for a number of
reasons of course there are less
burglars about but more particularly I'd
be interested in knowing from from the
Essex police whether there's been any
any link to crime prevention and
recommendations put forward by the
police and our people now increasing
their lighting locking their doors are
they putting alarm systems in in other
words is there something more yes there
being less burglars for more police but
there's no we know there's not more
please so it was less focused so is that
because you know we're doing a better
job on our own security and therefore
their preventive revenge - I can't say
anything we was told in other words the
prevention measures are being successful
from memory and such as remember from
the conversation in crime last week he
said with others Bolivia Swanberg will
be two days in the watch district
actually in terms of the network able to
make those farms it's a few steps
individuals so for example if you want
to go there's one person who committed a
series of burglaries it was cold so
there is a sense in which it's it's
certain individuals that thing Falls
large amount of problems so when one of
those people is saying I've handled and
dealt with it has a massive impact
locally so it's not preventative I'd
still be interested in I can understand
that what you're making the point you
know you can use if you get these serial
burglars off the streets then obviously
that has a much better more greater
proportion of effect upon the crime
figures but I was rather hoping that
people were listening and that we were
protecting ourselves and
in our homes better I'd like to hear
that you know whether that's the case
and if it isn't then you know I'm
thinking that this action plan ought to
have something in to to improve that
that's right
we've still got back this is a party
Thank You councillor mr. Boyd Thank You
chairman thank you for the ripple but
gets more comprehensive each meeting
other language my concern is always as
as ever is how we I suppose the echoes
of Polly walk counselor mr. John Mason
said it's about the the measuring others
the success of the CSP and it's just
concerned that some 2016 15 16 we still
have them for the 2017 18 such as
antisocial behaviors didn't there on out
you did fall a bit for a couple of
hundred incidents but it's still on
there so is what we are doing working
how do we measure what we working I
don't see a lot in the report about to
give me confidence about for each
individual program to twelve thousand
three hundred thirty seven pounds you
spent on it is actually delivery to miss
and how we measure the outcomes to say
that yes these these are worked and or
with the because I understand that's
work estimates place and said I'm aware
that there was the the road chose the
elderly people are quite popular and
Dane you get quite good take-up do that
do we actually go back and see if
they're taking the advises
canister mister said do they fit
programs do they do the Box do they
check things as they should do we follow
that up that's fontanka
I mean I do understand what you're
saying we don't follow up from senior
safety days now it's just that moment in
time what people attend us how
it was I think you know the impact
interest near the office so please Park
for Milan Commissioner have asked us to
measure the impact a little bit more
slightly then we do not ask personally
but every local authority and it could
be it's really difficult isn't it with
the action plan because there's lots of
small things on there lots of prevention
things and they're often difficult to
measure and the way we've done that in
the past is probably through surveys but
it's being recognized going forward we
need you to make the PAP served we need
to do a bit smarter I suppose and the
Commissioner has asked us to look at
that seriously and that might be here we
were talking just before coming in doing
slightly bigger projects rather there
are lots of small ones doing bigger
projects so we can measure it a little
bit more easier with the crucial crannis
probably similar idea in terms of the
work was done with the year six going to
you exactly storm when Grammys are kind
of doing the evaluations around that she
said how can we measure that this is
being effective because although it gets
good reviews on the time the children
love doing or not I attempted got myself
a fantastic day among lot of events that
how do we know this he's working so it's
part of his evaluation very much she
followed up the schools but it was
before the year six is left to say how
much have you actually remembered and
from memory I believe it was it was
positive action terms of what had
actually been retained
so that was trying to go beyond just an
evaluation on the day and actually
saying what are you actually learned as
a result of this about the senior safety
of I chose me tell you something that's
been not touching yeah in recognize we
need to measure not ask for local
authorities need to measure the impact a
little bit more effectively how that's
done with small prevention products are
not too sure about fear lots of happy to
have bigger projects where you can
measure it easier or there's the survey
work
it's difficult to measure that whether
our direct intervention has caused the
fall you'll insist thank you yes some
ten years ago the Metropolitan Police
cut their domestic murder rate by over
40 percent by intervening with couples
both partners not just looking after
somebody who's a bit of domestic
violence victim I know this because they
poached a member of my staff who was the
analyst on the program and the thing is
worryingly about essex they were late in
the game because the chief constable was
held to account of Majesty's
Inspectorate establish within the last
24 months about it at least the recent
disciplinary hearing deputy chief
counsel was all about the fact that he
lost his rag with the officer in charge
of the call center because I'm such a
backlog he couldn't see how they could
possibly be catching up in intervening
at the right time in cases like this so
when we look at the report and it
mentions of dealing with the victim and
they said well there is a countywide
scheme but really in looking at
ourselves it has to be kind of done in a
wholesome way and that didn't seem to
quite come across so they may be doing
though so my question would be you know
all they actually intervening with a
couples before it will gets out of hand
the way the maid did it and the way it's
recommended to be done or we sort of
like game and then catch up
because this is this does reflect on
serious harm to partners a relationship
once a just females every moment I mean
I can't answer for the police but I
don't say you know personally would
probably paying catch up to be honest
you know we're not probably doing
couples but just I'm probably working
with the surviving more than we are with
the perpetrator perpetrators are just
being killed you know from their dog
programs so to say it's still very
disjointed at the moment so that's where
family would help thank you thank you to
getting back to the one-to-one offending
that we all thought was talking about
earlier you have many projects obviously
for these twelve thousand pounds how
much work are we doing with that
one-to-one companies they're a lot for
you to do have we got that many on
called them patients for that one to one
yes enough survivors to have one-to-one
support every week everybody yes and
it's actually it was as police Cook was
called CLG it's a co d government-funded
Trailblazer product that's not just
Rochford its Buzzard n' castle point and
effectively it's like a one-stop shop
so when clients come in for support they
can get support about whole range of
things advised refuge accommodation and
so they don't have to have the same
conversation with lots of different
people and referrals come from you know
partners but also predominantly our
housing staff as well yeah I was gonna
say was are you finding that increasing
they think to die and
with that increasing that's going on
mommy you know as has already been
mentioned it if it is increasing then
the budget needs to increase to WB which
is something which needs to be looked at
I'm sure I mean it was once every two
weeks now it's once a week the draw on
the community safety budget is not
immense because obviously it's being
grant funded by central government we
just put in any further support we can
to support we believe on itself and
stuff so there's not a massive draw on
the partnership budget it just has an
indirect impact on the partnership
because all their partners can use in
get supportive life well I was going to
my other question that's where we have
this in several instances with I know I
found into the bunch of district council
to some get some sort of awareness to to
other residents of these people that
knock on the door basically and that
sort of thing where people have been
taken taken in given money and something
and I've asked for some sort of
something to be put on me with a website
or something in the paper or something
like that from not sure digital and I
was told time and time again we don't do
that why don't we do it and I wasn't
wearing that conversation I mean I can't
see any reason why we can't put
something out around scams and you know
be aware I'm glad we've done because the
press releases before about that so
happy to do that again I'm thinking we
county in there and if so yes happy to
do
there's around that then we'll turn our
backs we can know how many dogs tell
paws by the office that when I phoned it
in two occasions I was told though we
don't do that okay so you think it would
be nice to do them yeah thank you thank
you this is probably not so much of a
question there's probably something that
you probably can't answer but might be
interesting Pharaoh for other members to
to hear about this and I will see the
crime statistics are fairly core to how
you look at your priorities and it's
only where short priorities and so
therefore they're very important in
regards serving them the way that you
direct things and I had a conversation
with a certain police officer and he was
telling me about a number of different
ways that the police farm statistics are
massaged subject to the needs of having
a particular sort of focus so he was
telling me that if there's a particular
interest in burglary that the focus of
attention to reduce the statistics on
the burglary he says there's a number of
different ways that these burglaries can
be put down on the crime statistics so
it doesn't show these increase on that
particular crime so I'm concerned that
because we saw a light on the crime
statistics to form our focus
but how how accurate are they the only
thing I can say is that this serving
police officer was not a serving police
officer in ruptured or class requirement
but it does make me worry that there is
the opportunity that the the statistics
that we base a lot of our information on
are out are manipulated and they
manipulated for internal police
political reasons things like Nuiqsut
canals your back terminal we can make a
comment I mean that's a serious
allegation then and in an artifact I
suggest that if members think that that
is is is actually happening that's
something that you should you should ask
me to take up with the Chief Constable
because because you know in a clearly
manipulation of statistics is not you
know for you know to to yeah whatever
whatever you want to call it is it's a
serious it's a serious it's a serious
allegation and you know I have to take
that over the Chief Constable review
committee thinks that would be
appropriate
honestly I have furthered that rule that
before but it is a room about no
evidence obviously mr. chair one of the
difficulties with statistics is they can
be interpreted in different ways and
they I've actually qualified a statistic
so this so many different ways that they
information that you have could be
presenting it doesn't necessarily make
it wrong it's just it's just looking at
if you look at one way the hand is on
the left if you look at it from the
other side it's on the right and it's
that sort of situation I don't think I
think there's always going to bring down
the statistics because you start with
you've got very small numbers building
up and then you build up to an overall
picture and the overall picture can't
show detail it just can't thank you
thank you
essentially it while society is a
serving police officers um it's not it's
not a rumor or come from some third hand
it's with directly from someone who's
responsible opening its obviously as mr.
scrutton sizes it's a serious allegation
isn't it if Cass LaHood ways completely
assured in his own mind that he's spoken
to someone of integrity and experience
and I think he should make an
appointment to see in chief inspector
Wesley you'd actually discuss it not so
much from the point of view that he
should validates the conversation you've
had but to tell you
you can tell us the extent to which he
reviews the process in his division our
division to ensure that that doesn't
happen thank chairman Louisa
um as a statistics we talk about
statistics one of my questions really is
around how the statistics how we arrive
at those and reported crime I think when
the Crime Commission I came in last time
to speak to us there was problems with
people reporting crime so is that why we
see a decrease in dwelling burglary
because people that kind of fed up
trying to report the crime and just give
up but where it's crime with violence
you know they may be a bit more
persistent so really the question is is
can you ask the crime Commissioner about
the progress that's been made on there
was problems with 101 you know and the Q
times and things like that can we find
out if that's been improved since he
came in last and because obviously I
think that has a big bearing on these
statistics and the last thing is I have
got a question for Chief Inspector
Wesley which I'd like to talk to you
about afterwards if I may about
protecting vulnerable people
thank you Thank You chairman um it's not
an item that the Luise can answer but I
think residents would like to know
exactly how many officers we're going to
see on those streets
considering the DA's for precept was the
place of put in for you know we hardly
see anybody at all in uniform and also
6:23 board and I've known this for many
years 90% of residents in Rockford feel
unsafe in the local area of the dark you
know having business in Rutherford so
many people said to me they won't come
in to Rockford after dark first question
in terms of the increasing precepts
Roger hearse was cleared up I believe
117 years frontline place Oh police
staff I've paid 113 I believe it was
would be frontline policing they'd all
be divided across the different CSP
arrows and if you remember those a
request that went out to members a few
months ago in terms of actually when
those Dean front please stop I recruited
which will take time where do we want to
see in the gun that was a question that
was asked of members and also to the CSP
budget was clear because I I asked him
specifically at the police crime and
fire commissioners meeting a few months
ago that if our taxes go up in watch
were to pay for these we want to see our
fair share of those policemen here in
Watford and cops of point please and he
he said yes you will get your fair share
so I thought the intent to hold him to
that when I nexium ignited to no numbers
on it
yeah but he wasn't here we'll get our
fair share of those under the 13 did he
give you any indication with regards to
duration of time he didn't say he
wouldn't be drawn on that for me sorry I
mean if I mean just I mean I think that
I think the information it was
circulated to members and I got a number
of replies from members and I fed that
back to the police but I mean I think
the the issue is that there's a training
program for for the recruits and I
believe that you know could take up to
up to a year so there's a you know
there's that there's a lag time in terms
of the new recruits coming into the
system but we can we can you know we can
ask the police to to see if they can
give a more accurate time table as to
how they envisage that unpacking over
the next week while senior safety
partnership days you have Matt have you
ever thought about you going in to see
actual complexes like me love you got a
buddy creeper that three and white
believe you could put them together it's
up for personal or Islamic mother lives
in one you walk in there and nine as
soon as you press any buzzer they'll let
you eat you could just say you're
delivering and then if you go around to
the doors because the old dears think
they're safe all the doors are open so
it's you know I don't think the message
is getting out even so the older
generation but there could be these
complexes but they still need to knock
there from there on the front door
because someone come in to deliver
anything well then they can go around
250 bucks you know it's very very fun
one I don't think the message is still
getting out so them when they you do the
days because I don't love Duncan um I
appreciate that you pull the up but it
doesn't they aren't getting through they
must close their own front doors okay it
was just a thought I just I just know it
the idea yeah I mean that's probably
more easily achieves the whole idea of
senior safety days it's getting people
probably those that don't live in the
shelter complex people perhaps more hard
to reach you know in their own home
but in the same breath you know people
that are living in supportive housing
shelter complexes they're quite an easy
audience to try to get to you know it's
housing providers out there and can do
things through their only community
investment plan so this is just a
suggestion
Thank You chairman let's just go back to
the new recruits police officers I think
there's a hundred and seventeen increase
that they specifically 117 police
officers those under 13 years will be
going to front-line places 513 what
receives coming in across the county
across the campus across the county
could be fine dinner how many serving
police officers have resigned from the
stress of the job up until the new
recruits are coming in so are the new
recruits just don't be replacing the
officers because I don't know many
officers in the police for serving
police officers a lot of resign because
of the stress and the and what the job
entails now so are they just a majority
of them just going to be replacing the
ones that are designed or because the
police you're not increasing your police
force if you're losing a majority of
people come leaving the police troops
pretty stressed and the police new
police officers will we've had the
numbers yeah I mean interesting
presentation I was at a few months ago
but what your purse was there and the
Chief Constable was there the chief and
she talked about the stress that was on
frontline policing and he used the
phrase that the burnout the risk of
burnout amongst them and he was very
clear they were high risk of stress on
on fine police and I actually asked a
question what are you doing to work with
him to support them and actually the
police are increasing their support that
goes to those members of the force that
are struggling with mental health issues
with with burnout a whole range of
things so the police are actually more
aware of those issues and maybe there
have been in the past because it is
affecting someone facing in case a
counselor mrs. Ford did you yeah I was
just going to say that I'll link to naps
meet him and I can't remember the police
officers night she said it takes eight
months to
we crew a police officer it's all just
going back up more each day she's a
massive it's bad dreams
so she said you'll get all this money
what could be don't understand even if I
get a new crew still gonna take eight
months
Thank You chairman I'm getting back to
me when the 101 was introduced before
that was introduced it was introduced in
16 or 17 oh well going back to when he
was introduced well before it was
integers and if he's 2016 there it's a
system that hasn't worked and he's on
it's on its back really it's it's still
weed it's still with progressions
whenever they've got one eye one thing
kind of body but at least eight years
longer as if we know yeah I guess he
hasn't improved in many of the people
that our line has to wait on there for
40 minutes or 50 minutes and get fed up
with it those in favor really see so
therefore this will reduce the number of
maybe burglaries or easy own stuff going
on and I just wonder could you give us a
graph of when 101 was introduced and the
graph of the parent was used and how
many if you are 30 reads or whatever
there was complete there so it shows us
how he's going whether he's going down
whether he's going up in the way of
recorded offenses I will ask Jen whiskey
around my new one but I don't know you
can alter that Bob just saying can you
override any grasses and other things
I know 101 is something Rajasthan I
don't need some meeting so I gonna give
you as much as I can thank you so
chairman I've just found my nights when
of placing Kuan Commissioners meeting I
was attending back in December so the
question I often have a tea was that you
mentioned the peaceful so having a high
level of mental health depression stress
which is not to be underestimated as
nationally twenty percent of the general
population suffer from depression at
some point and can you really show me
that the police tougher getting all the
help and support that they need the
response that I was given is I can
assure you that the referral was now
taking one weeks not three weeks
officers that need the support indeed
the team is getting out two officers
were needed this week and we also
support as he falls short in terms of
the personal practice and we are
developing a hair of work so that was a
question that was asked months ago
council report was independent question
just to clarify I think we have just
found that the one other one was
introduced Louisa can you just add on a
couple of more questions for the
confirmation can you ask him about um he
was talking a lot about recruiting
specials and I understand that's been
gotten old
because of procedural issues and then
can you also ask him progress on
neighborhood watch because he was
actually quite easy enthusiastic by that
but
nothing so can you ask him what progress
is being made on that as well Thank You
champion and having to come back just
very quick one is around the community
messaging which was already one I forgot
this is they pushed by both pcc's Mosley
and to me but I don't actually think
I've had any messages fro use that
there's any mem what he cried a moment
was you still want me can we find out
what what he's going on because I think
we Thomas going to work it'll get better
I don't know what is what Robbie's
supposed to play with in this case
moments you can exercise to be a purple
really can be Island members of
indicators in question sorry report
mentions that to finish it that they're
not doing the recruiting new bone
specialist you in the echo every wait
there's an appeal for people to apply a
special if it helps I have got a letter
from the police asking if we can place
and I believe this has gone to all
councils and Essex and it's probably got
the whole range of other organizations
as well asking if we can place a note on
our intranet to see if there are any
officers any officers within the within
the local authority who might be
interested in volunteering as as as a
special so that does seem to be a view
that that specials are still part of the
overall policing framework and you know
as far as I understand there's still an
ambition to recruit
thank you very much my Soviet Chairman I
was running of cheer for a few years in
it I've thoroughly enjoyed it
[Music]
we have discussed this with the working
group with the committee's working komak
is just unifo Meechum sorry I
interrupted you external members and
also
and possibly an officer as well - I'm
from here I think it might be a
suggestion to invite our East of England
LG a representative gang Hughes - to be
involved in that because I'm sure he can
bring something positive to the to the
discussion as well mr. Chairman I think
that detail with Wayne and hope to
acknowledge should be left actually
working the room I appreciate the
information and the suggestions but I do
think the complexity of the doctrine
they need to decide what areas that want
to be explored and how we get people in
line to stop the objective assessment
Jonah had given me a thought I'm
wondering if we're talking about
professor Colin Curtis we're thinking of
inviting quite a number of people to
read the working group or to the
committee I'm just wondering if mr.
Scranton could reconsider that being a
presentation that is made to full
council because ultimately the
recommendations that are made through
this committee will would have to be
approved by full council and I'm always
very conscious that how about the
decisions everyone you know who has a
vote a full council is fully aware of
enough to speak with what the issues are
and determine so a sort of working
session of full council to hear
information you know ask questions that
could then be taken back for the working
group to to think about or is that
you know I don't think that was the
intention is it I was thinking it more
in terms chairman of an education we've
got the the task and the opportunity as
all counselors have previously had
because we've all had a copy of the
report to you know to really really
understand just what calling purpose and
his team has really been doing and I
know that stirrup in preemie number of
counselors said it's a really big
document to consider and sometimes you
know a presentation by word of mouth
using the dreaded PowerPoint can
actually help all members get up to
speed faster I'm concerned that when the
task group and the review committee come
up with recommendations it doesn't fall
into a void of those who have been
involved in those who haven't and if we
make really sure that all counselors
have the opportunity to get really are
deceived and involved then we know that
we will have a career and debate and
decision so I'm talking about education
and rather than getting ideas but of
course ideas will come it shouldn't be
you shouldn't you shouldn't ignore the
fact that questions are going to be
asked and people ask questions because
something occurs so if you will be
valuable in that respect as well but not
specifically
Thank You mr. I don't see any reason why
that can't be done as part of a full
council meeting we've done it before
we've had place come on give us a
presentation and look at the rather than
having a separate meeting it to
incorporate it into a full house I think
would be very helpful and I think
councillor Mason's point that if a task
group goes through this in detail and
doesn't report if the other members of
the council aren't familiar with the
situation and haven't had an opportunity
to perhaps exploring then the importance
of that report won't be lost so I do
think that's a very valuable but we can
Rickon we can seek to you know have a
conversation and I'm sure we can we can
organize we can organize that you know
I'm not sure what the time skills would
be this this that this general would
recommend it charcoal pencil gentleman
tell me there's no there's no reason why
the task group can't go off and start
working anything it doesn't have to wait
till you know coming purpose turns up to
brief everyone it can you can look at
the the detail areas that it needs to in
the first instance
because any do any members want to stay
I'm gonna say yes yeah and the working
group can buy other people to come along
and join them as as they see fit at the
first first meeting they have discuss so
we have a scoping meeting to decide if
we wish to expand the in working group
yeah yeah that's what I asked it
probably include John so program is
shown with the working group allows
substitutes bearing in mind the nature
of the work and doing it also we invite
them excuse
but they a issues of other people
thinking about and then we go buddy it's
time to fit utility cabinet member out
so that's I mean that they disgusting
escape sugar a pinch if they're a way of
perhaps quite yeah because if the
working group he's looking at this in
very fine detail and I think substitute
my made that difficult you don't know
what I'm sorry I think think if you're
gonna pass this task over to some people
in and they need to be able to get on
with even without chuckling been winning
in and out thank Jim I'm really making
the moment the the working group has to
mean during the daytime where most most
of us I'm also including more silk
because I do some work sometimes don't
see her home for nothing but thanks I
was going to be difficult in way of
working well it's not the task force
which is done
I mean I'd like to be up there but
obviously work sometimes and depending
on what the thing so yeah that's what
I'd say is that you know you can't
probably on this sorry I'm just being
completely nosy before the task force an
officer needs to be on it who is it oh
very easily define hm and I've
recommended obviously there you go UN
scrutiny officer who we we need every
level and I'd like to to ask mr. mr.
Bostick who I informally you know winked
at few minutes ago because I think he
would be
I suppose questions could be asked could
I suggest that an invite people down to
every member that when they read this
report they submit any questions or
queries to that working and of course
yeah I'm sure that what they gain that
could be decided going in the scope you
know I think that date should be set as
soon as possible on this he's already
good folks being I think it was a month
ago
beside we're already four months down
the line on a very important things I've
certainly I would have a meeting be
arranged within the next couple of weeks
to start with already
I just like to thank mr. Boston around
doing all this work and volunteering
obviously for a great deal more
seriously it may be a very helpful
summary and it's given a great deal
before and much of that caused us to
realize and understand that this is a
serious and deep issue
and is of importance and that's why we
decide to tackle it this way thank you
so thank you Thank You chairman if I if
I may and our members may wish to come
come back come back - it doesn't have to
be tonight but within what's being
produced is reference to house of
commons report on scrutiny and at some
point the project team stroke committee
might find it useful to to be looking at
that and they do and the other thing I
think I think in terms of a council
meeting
you know this disease if the committee
intent is there it's just about finding
the right meeting for that that session
it can be problematic all four members
in that if you suddenly find the council
staffs up with a lot of problems that I
mentioned it motions on notice you know
and if it really stacks up it it can
make for a long meeting but nevertheless
you know it's you you can never be sure
about and second-guess it so it's you
know it's seasonal see members happens
Thank You Jess well thank you
Tim thank you I mean and I guess you
know the reason they're there isn't a
written report is because there was a
report to the the executive on on this
issue very recently and you know there
isn't actually an awful lot to add to
what is what was said in that report the
South Essex local authorities have been
actively discussing the opportunity for
there to be a broader agreement about
how the how the South Ethics authorities
actually work together loosely badged
under the under the heading south Essex
2050 so very much forward look at issues
of mutual interest fraud of local
authorities across South Essex there
were a series of workshops with leaders
and chief executives over a number of
months and and that led to the notion
there was value in carrying on that work
and in due course reporting back on
whether or not there should be a formal
arrangement for
for local authorities in South Essex to
work together and that the intention is
that that report back would be in in
June of this year so that's the the
emails for there to be a report that
would be considered by the the various
surface its local authorities and a
decision could then be taken on the the
formalized structure and what governance
arrangements should be put in place to
for that for that association so that's
where we we find ourselves at the moment
so work continues at the moment in
relation to in relation to that that
proposition and there a number of a
number of work streams one is relating
to the proposition and what what is term
deal shaping and you know how that might
relate require marketing and engagement
and there are three other work streams
that are meeting at the moment to
discuss infrastructure industrial
strategy and strategic planning so the
pieces of work that are taking place
that will emerge in in due course in the
middle of the year for consideration of
from the consideration of the of the of
the various local authorities
Thank You Jenna I just like to
understand from the managing director
how certain things are likely to be
handled because at the moment as I
understand it from the Memorandum of
Understanding I only found it I only got
a draft from Google at one point but
Castle I think was Castle point or
Buzzard and they've been very helpful he
posted it so that was that was quite
good the the way it works if it seems to
be populated by the CEO or MD plus the
leader of the council and I think we all
know that councils are a great deal more
than just those two two roles and the
council's need to be involved themselves
so I'm going to ask imagine director to
just explain to the committee how he
sees at the moment issues being being
handled and one of them would be what
sort of authorization when he expect to
find from Roger District Council for
proposals to be put forward to any of
the four work streams he's talking about
and what authorization would be obtained
from dr. District Council for
consideration of proposals put forward
by other councils particularly those
that are face s of course but more
particularly there was an interesting
article in the Essex Chronicle about six
weeks ago where a thyroid cancer
actually proposed a matter of concern
the matter of concern was that a simple
majority of that body the body being a
seller would make a decision on all
and that him thirst survey a concern
that there may be issues that this
counselor doesn't agree with and yet we
seem to be being bound into a structure
that is simply a majority making a
decision on proposals and projects we
take them forward so the three three big
big points chairman the authorisation
from Roger District Council for the
leader amazing directed and proposals
forward to these work streams the
authorization to consider and agree to
proposals put forward by other councils
and the extent to which majority
prevails will apply and how it will
adversely have could adversely effects
brought for District Council I just like
your thoughts shown on those areas
because at the moment we we we as other
members and we are I am an upper member
I'm not part of any administration do
not understand how this is going to work
and how they will all be a democratic
process involved in other words of
governance and democracy Chairman I
think I made the point already that
those are the very issues that are under
discussion at the moment and unwilling
due course emerges proposals for the
consideration of the individual local
authority so they're all work well made
points and they're all points that that
need to be picked and proposals put
forward
you think the District Council should
handle those is it something you haven't
thought about yet or you and the leader
haven't thought about yet so that is why
you can't offer anything or are we
saying that you know we've got to we've
got to think about it what if we've got
to think about it how are we going to do
that there are no at this juncture there
are no firm proposals as to how that
will how that will hope that will work
and those proposals will be brought
forward over the next over the next few
months and the intention is in the
middle of the year there will be a
report to cancel on those issues and the
council along with the other councils
and Essex will need to make a decision
about whether they're happy with those
proposed governance arrangements I'm
sure you've misunderstood me completely
I understand you're going to talk about
this and although all of the council's
are going to come back with a considered
view to their councils but I'm
interested in what Rockford district
council thinks about this I'm not
interested you know at this stage I'm
interested what you and the leader think
should be the appropriate arrangements
to Rockford district council chairman
I've not discussed that issues yet with
the deliberative Council so I've got
nothing to offer the the the review
committee this evening chairman could I
recommend we we look at this again
without any coyotes will be reiterated
so quite a bit don't you think it's a
bit reckless for us us as a council to
enter into such an agreement without any
any comments arrangements people as I
understand it we've all had a copy of
the the bid for a hundred thousand which
we've read in the papers that has been
awarded on 11 let's know if it has or
hasn't been awarded to the this dry
working group working fund and we as
accounts live off at 10,800 I think your
compound even open hours to eight from
the firm might work with but that
doesn't seem too many governors doesn't
that worry you were told there's no
governing structure for this and then
we're talking about substantial sums of
money here we which has got indication
of how it would be spent but I've got no
nothing to show how we can make
expecting that that way I know they will
be presumably constraints round out and
be spent by the awarding body behind if
I can't see anything here to show that
doesn't cause first conserve children
sit there to slightly to the slightly
different issues at play here it's it's
clear that it's important that we we get
to a point where there is an agreed
arrangement for the governance of the
the the opposed Association of South
Essex local authorities so that's that's
one stream the other stream is around
the proposed preparation of a joint
strategic plan and that's what the the
bid related to and that was seeking to
deliver resources to around around the
development of a proposal to prepare a
joint strategic plan and the detailed
arrangements for that are also subject
to discussion at the moment and how that
would play out would will also be
reported in in the
in the middle of the year so yeah the
points are all well-made it's absolutely
essential that the governance
arrangements are are carefully
considered and are ultimately agreed by
the individual councils and you know
that all the process will be forthcoming
as I've said relationship times until
the middle of the year Thank You mr.
chairman
I must say that I was concerned about
this in the first place having heard the
managing directors comments I make more
concerned I would have thought that I
know you say it's going to be discussed
at the level that you're discussing but
I really thought it should have been
discussed at this council first that
this council should decide if he wants
to give authority to its leader and an
unelected person to commit the please
council business but basically what
we're talking about very fundamentally
this agreement has been reported has the
potential to take away democratic rights
as I see it of this council concern that
you can't tell us how you think it's
going to run because obviously you've
been involved in it for some time
concerned about the cost that law
officer more concerned about the
apparent loss of democracy this seems to
me like a mini a you if you like we're
giving our power to someone else
and elected or an elected person and it
is concerning and the governorship
should be agreed now this council not by
the third body chairman I'm sorry I have
made it very clear the governance
arrangements will be agreed by this
council camp councils are regularly
involved in informal discussions on a
whole range of issues and if those
issues are considered you know to the
point where
there is a view that the council shoot
in due course formally consider whether
those issues are something that the
council wants to agree to then they will
report be reported through in the normal
in the normal channel so I've made it
very clear the governance arrangements
will be reported through the council
that will be for the council to make a
decision on whether or not to accept
that those proposals it's still informal
discussions are taking place on on how
the suggested Association would actually
be be formed and and would be governed
so those proposals will come forward in
due course and I'm happy to come back
you know after later date and discuss
there was you know when those proposals
have actually have actually been worked
out my major concern is that the
proposals seem to be coming from a third
party rather than from this council it
just things back to front for me but I
appreciate that we're not going to agree
and that we're looking at ignore a
different angle so I can only be there
that'sthat's my concern is the way that
this has been approached and the way
that it's being activated shall we say
but let's hope that my fears are
unfounded terminologies I'm not sure
what the third party is you know they
there is a discussion informal
discussions are taking place and those
proposals will in due course come
forward for the council to consider
things except my definitely not was the
key to me
it's other perhaps the council basically
should have been more involved prior to
the stage right now yes much more in
fact and the Thank You mr. chairman and
the third party obviously is the South
Wessex that the organization that you're
forming or is being called that's the
third part it by definition I don't see
a problem we've got a big problem we
have funding problem across the country
with infrastructure problems and this is
a big thinking idea now it doesn't mean
to say that our representative can just
go and vote with unity what will happen
each decision in this route map will be
you have to come back here and we will
tell their representative how they're
gonna vote once we've agreed of course
give up the basic principle so this is
an early early stages at least that's
quite a bold move you were really to to
look at this because section 3-1 sums it
up tackling problems we cannot solve
individually law complaining about
infrastructure transport all kinds of
things medical all the rest of it
collectively this gives Essex clapped to
get it done but I quite agree it has to
be in the democratic process from the
bottom up because once the proposals
come in if we don't like something then
obviously we will tell our
representative by vote we'll make a
decision that they're gonna vote no or
yes depending haven't got to go I don't
see it as a clash it I actually see us
moving into the next plant for this
century
actually making it's somewhat better and
easier to live it really is it's a great
idea obviously it's early days and sean
has said he's going to come back to us
but how would he come from down at the
bottom where everyone's in the sort of
Babel as it were to think about
something higher up and getting this
family of councils to try and pull
together it would probably wouldn't
happen so someone never think of it
someone started
but then it has to go back through the
regular processes that we know and are
established it can't just take off by
itself so that I agree with that but I
don't think there's any intention for
that to happen
Sean's observations germinate but I mean
key them in thinking the thinking is
that in broad terms if there is some
scale in terms of authority working
together that provides a significant
opportunity to bring many of the things
that you know we all want to see in
South Essex to the table the opportunity
to make significant bids for
improvements to infrastructure you know
is is you know is key to key to all of
this you know the opportunity for
individual local authorities to seek to
obtain resources from the government or
from the let etc is limited and you know
if there's scale in there
local authorities working together in a
in a you know a cohesive way there's
real real opportunity and you know that
may very well be the message that in any
event comes through from the Thames the
template we commissioned John arleth
knew cheering that he's going to be
making recommendations in due course you
know so this is not about you know this
is not about setting aside the identity
of any individual local authorities this
is about trying to bring scale and you
know capitalise on on potential
opportunities to deliver in a better
place for for residents and South Essex
Chancellor Quinn and you know don't
think that they get too much of an
argument from members around this time
about the lack of strategic thinking in
English Roger that's taking place
particularly in South Wessex I've many
years em I think there is a requirement
for their strategic thinking I think the
question is more of case of whether this
is going to be top-down or bottom-up and
I think the preference around this table
is this needs to involve from the bottom
up and not being wholly stuff from us
from above mr. chary perfect just come
back or what one point I think my major
concern is the fact that from all I've
heard is that should this body decide to
go ahead and I suspect it will and that
we could be committed by majority eyes
Central Council email says that the
council will decide and ask our
representatives vote yes or no that's
fine but if the other case if we are
committed to a majority decision then we
are in a situation where this council
can say no and yet we are committed or
vice versa and that's where the concern
comes in
council Stanley Thank You chebula I
think it's always been my my concerns of
the audience we have only say one
representative to a meeting of what he's
proposed or how it is proposed of one of
you and I don't know if anybody else
knows about what proposals have been put
forward but all I haven't I don't know
does anybody else know what proposal and
that's something which I'm in the dark
with so to give somebody my authority to
talk formally when we know what they're
talking about what they're proposing I
find that very difficult to understand
to Germany the broad framework for
discussions are set out in the
Memorandum of Understanding which was
attached to the report to the the
executive thank you so I just wanna come
back to the comment that was made by the
pension director who exactly the money
you would use what informal
I'm still trying to head around the
paper nice to bid for 800 up to 1,000
pounds informally it does prefer me that
there's an informal arrangement around
eight hundred seventy one thousand
pounds that's why if I head around I'm
sorry I'm quite agree with the concept I
think you should be democratic
they put up of many members around the
table what I do I just can't but I'm
struggling to understand how we've
managed to get to a situation where
we've aligned ourselves an organization
which is big three hundred seventy one
thousand pound has been award feet as I
understand it and it's can be linked to
this because it's appendix two of the
report to the executive which is
attached to the memorandum of
understanding as well and but there's no
form
to a new place I just I will leave you
there I'm strapped it forwards well
terminology is that is that you know the
its it's good news in the sense that
there's nearly nine hundred thousand
times that gives the South Essex local
authorities the capacity to work on on
issues you know as I've said around the
the methods around infrastructure and so
on that clearly are matters that are
sort of lean the attention in insert in
South Essex but you know the bid was
submitted by the by the South Essex
local authorities in bouquet but the
government didn't it was appropriate to
award that money that I guess they that
they would not have they would not have
done so
but clearly the government felt that was
a look there was a piece of work that
was that was beginning to gel in the
marriage that merited merited support at
an early stage
come on has frequently asked of the two
hundred and sixty two thousand pounds
more breakfasts in a retrospectively for
1718 costs which include things such as
a review of the Essex strategic housing
market assessment does that mainly them
to receive some of this money for the
cost we've paid towards those items an
interesting question which I do it the
answer but I'm happy to I'm happy - I'm
happy to you know take the tip that back
and lock it also place their cars to the
root of the issue as I see it did you
say
is the is the planned date for the
reports America will be able to be
considered by the cancer since ethnicity
just not say that I did ask this
committee to to look at this issue in
front yes and understanding and
clarification we knows you know we can't
go to the executive and speak so there
was no chance of doing that of course
the council's issued a great number a
number of press releases saying well
good news it is and that's simulated
residents to to ask what I think of it
and I couldn't really give them a view
because it sounded like good news but I
couldn't tell you Carol our council was
participating in it apart from the fact
that two people were going to the
meeting so that's all I could say and as
well as the fact that council always
indicated that a large sum of money
seems to have been assembled so that's
how this question arose and I think it
was quite right the committee to to
pursue it this evening and try and get
an understanding of when those issues
will be exercised by this council and
then it exercised by those who are
participating in the work streams and
that's the order that I think residents
would expect the the other thing is
councilor Milne very kindly set out his
his view of how this might work and he
talked about bottom-up he talked about
democracy
he talked about proposals being agreed
here here being wrought for District
Council but I haven't heard Sean I
haven't heard you comment on what you
thought on the generality of what
Baldwin was suggesting if if you are in
the create agreement broadly with what
you say but I'll be happy if you're not
I want to hear some more well I mean
that's that's what one one one
suggestion and it it seems to be a you
know a sensible way of perhaps
approaching the the arrangements but
clearly there's discussions they've got
to take place and and I hear and
understand the points that you're making
in respect of the council's position and
the democratic process my own thoughts
are I think the managing director and
the leader and the deputy leader if
that's the appropriate case do need to
get together and give this committee
some form of signpost as to the
direction of travel and whether it's in
line with the thoughts of thoughts
circling around the table in particular
Council McMillan's is a very very kindly
proposal if you like of how the model
might be because I really do think that
before you know these work streams flash
out what's going to come back to us I
think we know we need to know a little
bit more about the direction of travel
we wrote for district count so kind of
take in relation to it mr. Joker that be
in writing it would be yes good a
problem with sharing information as it
as it as it begins to gel on the
marriage ship
sorry Jeff nothing misunderstood at the
managing director is indicating that
there be some form of decisioning made
as a result of the combined thinking of
a seller by June but before that I think
the the leader deputy leader and the
managing director need to get together
and put to those committees he's writes
the question what what basis some
direction of travel with regard to the
issues of governance and the involvement
of the democratic process in Rockford
District Council will apply because
that's what we that's what so we in the
moment we don't know we do that though
so I think that needs to be determined a
little early you know April I would
suggest a problem yeah if that's not an
imposition on you
chairman I I'm I'm not clear at this
stage whether or not those discussions
will have you know this council to
approach those Chairman the tronic II
will beat again responsible for
determining what you mean
so chairman I understand that point that
you know the the the discussions about
how the governance Arrangements might be
contemplated is is a discussion that all
local authorities in South Essex but you
know are are considering you know so
Jenna you know
I've done a number of these things in a
commercial arrangement I've taken
briefings from my my staff my managers
my directors when I've participated in a
development work stream and I've been
used to taking with me a very broad
understanding of what my business wanted
to see put forward it doesn't
necessarily mean that that's likely to
be well certainly to be agreed but I
think what I'm suggesting and other
members seem to have agreed with me is
that the managing director the leader of
the council and deputy because that's
appropriate do need to have some sort of
understanding between them before they
wander into a room to discuss what these
arrangements might be and an idea of
what proper district council is likely
to want and I don't see why this
committee can't hear them
- chairman I'm not going to commit to
come back to a meeting in April with you
know with such proposals because I don't
know whether those will be available at
that point of time surely you can't
discuss with the legal counsel and
arrange to meet with them to discuss
this issue I can certainly do that well
I can do that right but I can't commit
to bring back proposals as to exactly
how Rochford Council would envisage
governance arrangements you know - to a
meeting in April I'm not clear that
given the time skills that those that
information will be will be available by
then do you not think it would be
prudent to have prior to taking the
coach nation's birth I don't necessarily
disagree with that with that point that
I'm not at this at this juncture but I'm
not willing to commit to a timescale
there's just one clarification on that I
follow your your scheme of thought and
it makes sense to me if something's
coming back to this council from a
product of what a seller thing the
government's arrangement should be and
that all council should agree to being
clearly we've got to take something into
the room beforehand I can't understand
why if it's coming back to this council
as a proposal former seller in June why
the timescale isn't obvious
so you are if you're still not willing
to commit to a time scale to come back
to this committee you know I'm quite
happy to come back to this committee in
April but I'm not I'm not willing to
commit to come back to this the this
committee with with a detailed view and
how the council would would present its
its case to the discussions at the
salient into this debate and surely you
will have a business plan to take
forward to to introduce to to other
councils on your ideas or repair or
ideas or at least this pain I don't know
what that is at the moment I haven't I
mean from what I can understand at the
moment is that we're going to go to this
open committee and listen to what
everybody's views or what they want but
we've got nothing to put forward we've
got to have some sort of a business plan
that we're going to put forward to make
it worth motley now in their direction
as well as everybody else's direction so
if we're going there with no business
plan and sold things you know we've got
really nothing to say am i right you've
got the Beasties pain I mean that's the
whole point of the exercise you know is
to have a business plan that you're
gonna deal with well you can't be there
to folder on you to be honest you don't
know what the other law was even
thinking about it doesn't need to know
until you goes to the to the meeting to
find out how they're proposing the dual
they've got the business plan you
haven't got em do you know that you're
certain you just say thank you thank you
I would expect it if somebody's going
into discussions as you put it
I mean jus that you'd have an objective
how's the meal very clearly outline up
potential right forward very clearly and
it's one way of thinking but you've so
far not being able to tell us how how
you're thinking of the way forward what
this committee is simply asking is if
you're going along here if you're going
along with no objective then you might
so you're just going to do what you're
told so presumably you either want to
know what the objective is what do you
want to gain from that you said if you
want an overall strategic thinking
planning infrastructure you joined up
thinking yeah it sounds really good
you've got no idea how you want to do
that and that's what we're asking we're
saying find out think about what you
want to achieve and how you want to
achieve it
and you perform us I think that's
another way of putting it no I can't
think of another simple one people can't
a business plan yes there is another way
of looking at it you don't going to be
in negotiation he's always gonna go
straight except with Europe of course
it's not a negotiation but it sounds
like you're walking into a situation
that maybe it's just like Europe that
everyone's going to tell us what we want
well you know we're we're journey around
and saying look it's a negotiation if
you walk into a negotiation
you've got your heads of terms of what
you want to achieve
and therefore you know you know your job
necessary you've got some red lines
you've got some that you've got
opportunity to listen and mainly agree
something slightly different and the
relationship the various models that are
available the extent to which you engage
with the other people you negotiating
with i'd expect there to be for this
negotiation the three of you or two of
you to have a heads of terms that you're
going into thinking of shows from with
two guys you as a team if there is a
problem if there's more than one of you
then you need to have shared if you
haven't shared that you can end up
actually arguing with each other and
that's something I've learned that in
business the high that will again show
you you know so you don't do so all
we're asking is for you the managing
director the the leader at the very
least to sit down and work out for opera
district canceled what you see the heads
of terms to be in the negotiation you'll
be undertaking in working in those work
strengths to ensure our best interests
are all delivered a part of the
democratic process it's not for you or
the leader to simply decide on their own
you don't have those powers
so therefore this OP this overview and
scrutiny committee because that's what
it is is saying well we've asked the
first question which is what are your
heads in terms and you're telling us you
don't have them yet okay you don't have
them yet you know that you're going to
bring back a proposal in June so
therefore between now and whenever that
work string starts you've got to have
decided
what's your heads of terms let me go to
show you are so you must have some idea
on your timeline when your parents are
going to do that and we're asking when
are you going to do that and can you
come
just before you enter the work stream I
can't put in plainer than that Shawn
because that's all I've done all my life
in business his workout plans chairman I
think I indicated that didn't that
didn't in principle disagree with work
with I think we may be talking in a
slightly across purposes I think the
point I was making was the you know if
you said you wanted to meet on the 12th
of April I wasn't going to or whatever
the date was I wasn't going to commit to
be able to come back to a particular
date of this of this committee I don't
disagree with any of the any of the
points and principle that have that have
been made other than other than that
it's the whole point of asking for April
because otherwise we're into June and
it's too little and the managing
director should be aware that there's no
meeting in May and therefore we're not
being unrealistic to ask for an April
date I suppose we could always have a
special meeting we can have a special
meeting meeting with the managed service
from the leaders don't oh yes if they
can't manage fake well we'll have
another meeting on a schedule weeds is
April the 10th if you're not making with
image that would you be willing to
consider and discuss with the leader of
the council about coming back to this
committee meet you I'm happy to have
that discussion
it's only suggestion but we can take a
strength from this because if we have a
plan because we know what we fit in the
big scheme of things that is more
effective not not actually having that
when you actually turn up for the
meetings because you can steer things
and that's probably an important way to
look at it so from that point of view
that can be very constructive no not
getting away it could be really
constructive emphasize that enough
maybe yeah I think it's the general
consensus they we would like to see I
would like to invite you and the any
done for yourself to come back to us in
April with a date that you you want pose
if the 10th of a Poisson convenient and
to bring this oh I have that discussion
yeah
16:17 private sector housing policies
that reporters should be coming out this
week possibly tomorrow device moving on
to number 119 credit debit card payment
car parks this the decision has been
moved to June 19 moving all you've got
to iet the a12 7 air-quality project in
the strategic outline business case I'm
expecting that to come out or the report
to come out this Friday if any of you
have got any questions
Marlene is quite happy to take colors
will this be an open document for the
public to see there's a lot of people
asking questions about it you know be
ashamed if it wasn't this all see been
sorry to interrupt but there's obviously
been a fair bit of information in in the
media about aspects not directly related
to but there are other interlinking
issues I always get my information from
the media your environment
yeah it's twice
and that one is a strategic outline a
business case and then if you notice 318
is the only one of these have an air
quality project the out on final
business case we are in that so I'm good
Louise unapproved a lot for the chairman
it refers to the shortest possible time
frame and I'm sure I'm going to be it
short the season strong as possible so
I'm fine but we we put the decision to
be made by November 18 all that might be
this one--this possible time
so I'm afraid it doesn't look likely a
very short period of time to me or to
mentor the public is that the shortest
possible timing is that future
consultations that can be in the
government time frames selfish needs
and then this point one point in the
street singing especially what's this
about
please I think it's about whether we use
our street scene officers for
enforcement not particularly certain on
that office not even this week so I
couldn't chairman if somebody it is it's
it's about enforcement of infringement
of things that happen within their what
you know within the public realm you
know so whether it's whether it's I
think it's you know all the things
really defy tipping litter you know that
the little dog fouling using the police
powers that we've got comfort Leafs and
I believe so yes
just a clarification sex and how offices
have legal it seems we've issued it
follows it's probably a stupid question
to ask but have you got anybody that we
got enforcement officers out there at
the moment or will we have any
enforcement officers there there later
yes yes we have
certainly I know we played one that
straight saying officer that enforces on
flying yeah I'm talking about a ten not
on fly-tipping not on not on patrol yeah
that's what I'm talking about we so how
do you wait how do we you know how do we
deliver the ticket where we don't fail
it or whatever he's written and what
have you have we got any in the moment
whatever we haven't we have an officer
that does deal with actively with fly
tipping you know I think the question is
to see what the opportunity is within
the unlimited resources that the council
has available to tip to actually act on
these on these perfect so that's insane
we haven't got any officers enforce
anything
yeah well I think everybody knows that
already Polly you know that's the reason
why it happens money to its role was a
bigger one in water Elaine's day
[Music]
the team we also do with pension into
the sanctuary housing development yes
possibly no he's also penciled in
everything on the operation and
development I think that's premature
church at chairman if I might suggest to
the overdue written the officer I think
that would be probably best placed in
the next municipal year okay that's
that's my opinion it's a very big big
job all right
that will work believe a certain officer
well my case I'm losing it those are
bright oh I've been pressurize it's ok
that's that's fine and then in relation
to sanctuary is that is there anyone are
we expecting anyone from centuries we
involved in arrows at novice
originally I was asked just for officers
to
this issue granny old sanctuary have
asked if they can attend I suggest it's
in two parts I mean clearly there's an
agreement in signed on the 8th of June
2016 with century the purpose of asking
officers to report to establish has the
agreement being fulfilled and in the
second part if if if if sanctuary wish
to join us afterwards if they've got
anything they wish to update to
something that would be welcome they
would like to attend because they've
been discussed chairman it's up to us
how we organize our business if we if we
are asking for a review of the agreement
that the council's made with sanctuary
then in many senses it's about has that
agreement been fulfilled
that is a that is a function of our
offices and deliver and for us to have a
discussion with our offices not with
sanctuary because there are a party to
the agreement it would be singly
improper to do so because it's not a
negotiation or a litigation it's a
factual exercise as to whether the
agreement has been fulfilled or not the
extent to which if it hasn't been
fulfilled in certain areas that's not a
matter for that for this committee to
take forward with sanctuary there's a
matter of our offices with the the co
party to the agreement so my view would
say that we have our officers report on
the agreement and the extent to which
it's been fulfilled or not and this this
committee s the opportunity to question
that and if if after that another
another item on the agenda if you wish
if we wish and sanctuary wish they can
come and update is further if they
that's what they want to do
but they shouldn't be the first part of
the meeting when the officers are giving
their report
it's our officers reporting to the
committee except in Sam Sam that sounds
quite logical to me mr. Spock was there
[Music]